where are you in jail like is co-parents
is one bad cop is one good cop or how
does it work J would probably say that
I'm the good cop and he's the bad cop
Oh would you say that's probably true I
know how to set boundaries I know how to
get them in check camon my oldest is an
amazing kid he listened so well my
daughter Saylor is the happiest easiest
baby it's Jackson our middle child that
is our wild child revel so he's the only
one we feel like real in sometimes but
um but he's he's hilarious and he just
has so much personality Kristin
Cavallari he opening up to me about life
with her husband Jay Cutler and their
three kids who are all under the age of
four their new baby daughter Saylor
was born in November is she talking yet
she's making noises and stuff like that
you know but um no she's been rolling
over for a while now I feel like she'll
probably be crawling her in the next
month and a half or so so that's very
exciting do you guys wanna have more
kids
I don't three you know now that we've
got our girl to you know it's it's nice
she's sort of shifted the balance in our
house and the energy has really changed
and it's it's a really nice feeling
she's been very calming for everybody
we're all just very happy right now
Kristen certainly has her hands full but
she's got the art of multitasking down
bikinis and breast pumps I printed out
this picture of you lovely photo what's
going on here this is my life these days
pumping at the pool multitasking I'm
actually gonna go pump right when we're
done with our view this is my life it's
every three hours aside from raising her
kids at Kristen just relaunched her
jewelry line emerald of you have a
husband you have three kids you have
this jewelry collection the book the
shoes where do you sleep um you know I
mean I'm really lucky I am a
stay-at-home mom you know for the most
part I cook dinner almost every night
and you know I'm taking my kids to
school I'm go to the grocery store and
then you know when I need to I can make
time to focus on the jewelry or the
shoes or whatever it may be
you